greetings welcome back to yet another
analysis from
the uh second season of the uh
champions chess tour and uh from
the first tournament skilling
open so today
or this time rather we will take a look
at hikaru nakamura against the young
ponyachi a very important victory for
for nakamura and it was a very good
game as well and that is the reason i
wanted to
show you guys uh this uh game so let's
take a look here one e4 c5
the palm notch is known for his sicilian
seems like he's kind of uh
stepped away from his uh his french
so he is back to schneiderf and knight
f3
d6 and niger is
is shown here after d4 takes takes
knight f6 knight c3 and the move a6
there are tons of other options there
and one of them being g6 which is the
dragon
and another one being the classical
sicilian after knight
c6 benjamin holderson made an
excellent video series on this on
chess24
but i digress so let's take a look
so after a6 white can play pretty much
every single playable move let me
mention a few
f3 bishop e3 g3
h3 h4 bishop e2 bishop d3 bishop c4
queen d3 bishop g5 which was usually
uh considered the main line probably
still is
rook b1 even a3 a4 not b3
you get it you can play anything in this
position and
a lot of moves are extremely dangerous
so when you play the night or if you are
required to know
a lot of theory f4 as well of course
but nakamura he decided to go for bishop
d3 which is
nowadays a fairly rare move you do not
see this one
very often i don't believe it is
particularly
critical either um
i think g6 in this position is quite
quite interesting because you get a nice
dragon
and white doesn't really get his attack
going bishop d3 is not
that good for white in the dragon uh
so g6 there is interesting and
but napoleon actually did something else
he played e5 which is a very standard
move um this kind of establishes how the
game will go on
uh because in najdorf with black you you
usually play either e6
or e5 if you play e5 you weaken the d5
square quite a bit but you get play on
the dark squares
and if you play e6 you will usually
follow up with b5 bishop b7 and 97
knight 95 and potentially 97 knight c5
as well or knight b6
97 knight c5 that's a lot of arrows but
this
usually happens and i can't even show
that i suppose
so many arrows on the screen but for
example in um
in a night or if like bishop e3 e6
and f3 e5 queen d2
for example and then bishop e7
yeah this has played quite a bit maybe i
might be messing up but you get the
point
just trying to explain the ideas here
but 92 is played by nakamura e5 by
napomnerchi
of course um and
i would assume that it's very possible
to go here too
and then maybe play for an attack once
again
but it's kind of a disadvantage to have
the bishop on d3 and
one of the main issues is that it's
easier now for
for black to play d5 and if black is
able to play d5
it's going to do quite well so 92
there should be seven castles castles
and then
knight g3 logical move you want to play
f4 or knight five in the future maybe
even take on e5
uh and you do still prevent d5 which is
important because we can take and if
black takes we take back
it's not possible to take because the
pawn on h7
is taken and the queen as well nice
discovery there
this is kind of important but the bishop
is moved to e6 instead
for the reason that he wants to play d5
the nakamura he wants to avoid that so
it puts his knight on d5
takes takes and the pawn structure now
has been slightly established here
the diagonal is open but in return black
can now put his knight on c5
which is a very nice square the knight
will be standing
up quite quite well and maybe even
at some point put the bishop on b6 this
diagonal right here
or maybe also play g6 and then later f5
these are black's plans
white wants to play c4 maybe even f4 in
the future is to try to open up a little
bit because white has the bishop pair
opening up the position will at least
sometimes
be quite advantageous one of the
problems with playing f4 though is that
it gives away the e5 square so we've got
to be a bit careful about that
but g6 is played again one of the plans
i mentioned
c4 knight bd7 same moves that i
also mentioned earlier here jumping to
c5 is going to come
so a3 this move is quite common
knight c5 bishop c2 the point of a3 is
to simply play b4 in the future and kick
away the knights
just that uh
white needs to be careful when you place
b4 so the pawn on c4 doesn't get
severely weakened
though i should mention that
and here in the napoleon she makes his
first error and that's to play uh b5
uh the problem with this is that it
weakens the
the pawn and b5 quite a lot and it's
squared on c6
b4 could come very quickly as you can
see here b4 knight
b7 black's pieces are already looking
very bad compared to what they were
looking just like
three moves ago like this so b5 is
pretty uh pretty inaccurate maybe it
would have been better
to push h5 here the point being that h4
could come and kick away this knight
and that's not so easy to deal with
because you should never play h4
yourself because that pawn is going to
get taken
quite quickly so h5 would have been uh
very interesting and then later h4 but
napoleon actually played b5
b4 from nakamura knight b7 takes takes
and then bishop h6
another tempo rookie 8 is the fourth
move and bishop d3 so we now see what i
was mentioning here
the pawn on b5 is very very weak
this also does work out nicely
tactically
so knight 65 is a forced sequence you
can
take a look at the evaluation bar here
and you notice that the
advantage here is it's going through the
roof and the position is simply lost
except the knight takes d5 queen f3
white wins
wins a piece it's uh there's nothing in
the palm that you can do in order to
save
uh save his knight uh and here
you don't really have any moves because
if you play something
in b6 i can always simply play bishop e3
and then kick away the queen again
so you cannot protect this pawn and if
you get this position
you are completely lost and as a matter
of fact the advantage is
um it's like plus five which is uh
sounds crazy but
uh it's dead lost so let's take a look
65 queen of three knight c3 queen takes
p7 white is now up a piece of course is
completely winning
let's see what happens uh d5 is another
[Music]
is a way to try to trap the queen bishop
d2 saves today
because we simply have queen a7 after
rook b8
and it's not so dangerous because now we
can survive like this
and if d4 is played we can then simply
check on c3
the queen is not going to get trapped
so let's take a look knight e4 was
played kind of a tricky move if you take
him with the knight you lose a piece but
nakamura took with the bishop
takes rook ft1 very simple chess here
f5 these pawns are a little bit scary
but this position is
lost bishop c3 the ship d6
you can't allow the trade of queens
queen e3 simply
queen f6 bishop b2
bishop c7 queen b3 check king h8
and now rook d7 very nice to get the
rook on the seven
seventh rank here maybe play rook f7 and
then rook d1 later to try to double on
the
seventh rank which would be uh
killing should be six rook d1 very
simple
rookie six he cannot allow he cannot
allow rook f7
bishop c1 is played here
nakamura wants to put his bishop on h6
rook b
rookie 8. i mean i still think bishop h6
here
is that looks like the game is over to
me
even though it still is because of the
extra piece but he played bishop e3
takes six he simply wants to trade more
pieces
and after h5 rook c7 came
h4 knight e2 f4
e takes f4 e takes f4 and here a very
very nice tactic
knight x f4 and the game is
officially completely over it went from
over to uh
there's no way you will ever save this
game over that's how over this is
um and the reason this works is that if
you take
itec on e6 and if you take back
there isn't there is a mate after rook
t8
and another important point is that
queen takes c7 is met by queen takes e8
and that's also completely completely
winning
and if you're not going to take back on
f4 you uh
will lose and another thing
uh i also can mention is that queen e3
is also just met like
king h1 or queen king f1 and there are
no checks at all
black is lost so the palm that she tried
with rook f8
but after queen takes c6 quintex f4
queen b6 preventing queen f2 and queen
f1
h3 queen d4 check and then rook c6
pinning the rook he resigned
in a standard game he probably would
have resigned as
early as queen f3
here i think he must have missed this
because after this the game is
technically completely winning
especially on this level
but of course he decided to play on
because it's rapid
we got nothing to lose right so i
resigned
uh so that just shows how our b5 it just
went completely wrong after that
so playing something like h5 would have
made a huge difference
after b5 the position is very very bad
and could
even be so bad that it's objectively
lost this was a very important victory
for hikaru nakamura who now
is ranked as number
six uh this vic defeat wasn't a
crisis for an apogee who is right as
number
five actually he's sharing the same spot
with
nakamura so they're both doing well when
they will be heading
into the last day tomorrow
and it will be decided who's going to
qualify for
the knockout stage do stay tuned